so some people might find this
interesting or maybe depressing
remember how a couple of weeks ago i
mentioned
i had a covet test and the reason i had
a covent test
is uh when i got back from our show
vacation
i was in martha's vineyard i was having
some headaches and tiredness which could
be nothing
could be covered could be allergies
could be something else altogether
so my doctor initially said just because
we really don't want to miss it let's
first do a covet test and rule that out
we don't want you walking around
contagious if this isn't allergies
if it's coronavirus so we did the covid
test
it was negative okay good we ruled that
out so then my doctor said let's just
get a bunch of standard blood work uh
we'll we'll check your blood counts
we'll check for infections we'll check
liver function because martha's vineyard
has a lot of ticks
let's rule out lyme disease i wasn't
aware of having been bit by a tick but
seems smart martha's vineyard and some
of those islands i think block island
nantucket
i think there's a heavy heavy amount of
tick uh
flying around walking around there do
ticks fly i'm not even sure
in any case i wasn't aware of being bit
by a tick but my doctor
in an abundance of caution said let's
set up the blood work i go in
there's no wait the phlebotomist sits me
down
great service i'm in there for five
minutes bing bang boom
nine vials of blood lighter i head out
and everything looks fine
that five minute visit was thirteen
hundred
forty two dollars worth of blood work
you have to see this bill i got
which we're going to put up on the
screen for our visual
audience so you've got the puncturing of
my vein itself
that was 16 i guess that includes
the alcohol swab and the needle
and who knows whatever else some of the
blood tests are cheap so for example
like my basic blood count was
only 83 dollars the liver function test
which is the c reactive protein that was
53 dollars
and then some of these tests are way
more money so since i was tired
we were looking at thyroid that one's
176 dollars
checking for lyme disease was 150
something called dna rna
zika i guess just testing for zika virus
that was uh
almost 500 and in total
this was 1342.
uh out from which my insurance
negotiated
a big discount for themselves and paid a
portion of it
leaving me with a 75
uh copay i guess you would say for the
blood work
this is another one of those examples of
a fundamentally broken system
and there are so we could do an hour on
each of these aspects
the huge sticker prices to account for
insurance companies negotiating
discounts to account for people without
insurance
or people who never end up paying huge
sticker price
and then negotiating down five minutes
in the hospital
theoretically thirteen hundred dollars
for someone
seventy five dollars for me because
i pay 500 a month for my insurance
in other words when i got my
appendectomy i mentioned
i had to pay my full 2 000 uh
deductible i paid 500 bucks a month for
insurance
to have the privilege of only owing 2
000 for my appendectomy
here i am paying 500 a month in my
health insurance premium
to have the privilege of only owing 75
dollars for the blood work and of course
all of this
is a complete disconnect from the real
actual cost of these things trash
broken system uh and we i mean listen i
wish i could say
joe biden wins and we fix it but we know
it's much bigger than that joe biden
wants a public option and to negotiate
some drug prices
we need a much bigger systemic change
it's worse with trump
but this is going to be i mean i i don't
want to be pessimistic but
i think in the best case we've got a
decade before we really make
substantial change to this system uh and
we'll be talking about that more for
sure once we know
who will be steering the ship for the
next four years
one of our sponsors today is vincero
watches
and they're giving you 15 off everything
in the store
if you're a guy looking for the perfect
way to refresh your style
one of the best investments you can make
is in a high quality
wrist watch vincero is an american
company
that has made it possible for everyday
people to afford
a premium watch almost everything they
sell is within the range of about two
hundred dollars but it'll look
like you spent a lot more all of their
watches are made in small batches from
top quality materials and they just look
great i went on their site and picked
out
a watch from their icon automatic
collection the one i got is in mesh
matte black and i love it it's simple
sleek elegant
goes great with just about anything i'm
wearing and i've gotten a ton of
compliments on it
you'll get 15 percent off everything in
their store
when you go to davidpakman.com vincero
i've put the link right underneath this
video